hello there
um welcome to another episode of Science
and Technology q a for kids and others
and I see all kinds of questions here
let's see where should we go first
um I see a question from Joss can you
talk about about Pangea how the
consonants shift is it possible to
reform Pangea is the technology that
could prevent this
okay so first
first thing is you look at a map of the
Earth today
it has its continents arranged in the
way it has them arranged
it hasn't always been that way and it
won't always be that way if you look
back 100 million years for example uh to
when there were dinosaurs running around
and so on the configuration of
consonants was considerably different
and for example famously kind of South
America and Africa were kind of glommed
together as as were a bunch of other
consonants
um in arranged in different ways you
know it's an interesting story in the
history of science it was a people as
soon as there were decently accurate
maps of things like South America and
Africa people said gosh if these were
puzzle pieces you know Africa would fit
into South America how can this be and
people was a trap called Alfred Wegener
who was big on this were like well maybe
there is continental drift maybe in fact
these continents are moving around on
the surface of the Earth and maybe at
one time South America and Africa were
fit together and then they broke apart
and now they're a distance apart and you
can see the two sides would fit together
if you if you put them together as
puzzle pieces and for a long time people
were like no no that couldn't possibly
be that way you know there's no way this
is real
it took a long time and then eventually
continental drift was discovered the way
it was discovered
was that there are uh there are the the
magnetic field of the earth
magnetizes rocks at
um and uh what what was discovered was
and it does so that the Rocks kind of
get Frozen in their magnetism when they
when they cool
um after they've been produced as you
know lava from a volcano or something
then they cool into Solid Rock and then
things about their magnetism get set and
you can kind of see these rocks had
magnetic field that was set in this
direction and these ones in this
direction and you realize that actually
these were uh these these rocks had to
be sort of in the same place on the
surface of the Earth at the time when
they were formed and that was kind of a
clue about continental drift about the
fact that actually the continents are
moving around on the surface of the
Earth
nowadays it's actually possible to make
measurements with radio telescopes and
things uh tell it using the radio
telescope technology but but basically
making Precision measurements where you
can actually measure directly the um
uh the motion of consonants in fact
people have even considered the
possibility that with the GPS's built
into cell phones that if you could
collect all the GPS data from all the
cell phones that somehow you would see
this kind of overall flow of this tiny
amount of of drift of consonants moving
on the surface of the Earth I think the
fastest moving ones I think Australia
New Zealand I think they're moving
pretty quickly like maybe oh what is it
could be what is it a millimeters or
centimeter per year something like that
it's of that order of size that they're
they're moving in a certain direction on
the surface of the Earth how does that
motion work well basically the center of
the earth we go down more than 50 miles
the Earth is liquid
um there's there's still
Remnant heat from when the earth was
formed 4.6 billion years ago maybe about
half the heat of the earth is just the
result of heat that was in it when it
formed when when all the pieces of the
earth were pulled together by gravity
back when the solar system was formed
and the other half comes from
radioactive uh elements in the earth
that are decaying and producing energy
and that's another source of heat inside
the Earth but whatever the source the
result is that the Earth has a liquid
core
um and uh in molten core it's it's not
liquid like you couldn't pour it
um you know if you picked it up I don't
think it would it would like pour I
think it's much more viscous than that
but it is liquid in the sense that it
flows its molten rock that flows around
um and more than about 50 miles down
that's that what that's what you'll see
now essentially what's happening is that
the consonants are floating on the
surface on the surface of that liquid
and different things are happening there
are places where pieces of um whether
sort of an upwelling from the liquid
core and on the two sides of the
upwelling you're producing uh more crust
more solid crust there are other places
where the where it's being pulled down
um so in let's see where are they
there's uh in places where there are
lots of volcanoes
um there are lots of lines of volcanoes
those are the the borders between these
uh these plates so the the things that
are sort of the solid pieces of the cusp
crust are so-called tectonic plates
those are the things that are kind of
floating on the surface of the of the
mantle so on the earth I don't know how
many there are maybe 20 30 plates
something like that
um 20 30 blocks of solid stuff that are
separately floating on the mantle and
the boundaries between these plates
things happen like you'll have volcanoes
or you'll have earthquakes where there's
motion between in these plates like in
California there's the San Andreas fault
that runs uh uh near San Francisco and
so on
um where they're at a small rate these
two different plates there's there's two
plates that are moving relative to each
other and what tends to happen is most
of the time it's just um the thing has
uh there's sort of a continued kind of
force of moving one plate against the
other and just like when you pick up an
object a ruler or something and you put
your fingers underneath it and you'll
see that you'll you'll it'll stick for a
while and as you move your fingers
together it'll stick and then slip stick
and then slip and so on the exact same
thing happens between these tectonic
plates it'll stick for a while and then
it'll slip and at the moment when it
slips that's when an earthquake happens
um and uh that that's the but there's
there's in the end the plates are moving
relative to each other they tend to not
move smoothly relative to each other
they tend to go stick and then slip and
the moment when they slip is the
earthquake people wonder could you
lubricate The Faults could you pump some
fluid down into the faults to lubricate
it so it wouldn't stick so it would just
smoothly Glide I don't think that's been
a successful thing that's been done but
that's a sort of an engineering at some
kind of geoengineering thing that one
could imagine
now in terms of of
what can one figure out about these
plates sort of floating on the surface
of the on the mantle
um there are things happen when these
plates crash into each other you'll
they'll they'll push up and you'll get
mountains like the Himalayas and things
like this
um when uh
um you know a variety of different
things happen over long periods of time
over periods of tens of millions of
years and things like this
um the uh there are these maps that kind
of show based on the plates as they are
today you can kind of work backwards
saying this plate is moving you know the
Australia plate is moving at a high
speed where was it originally well you
can kind of move you know you can you
can project backwards and say where did
it come from given that it's moving in
this direction now if you do all that
projecting backwards one of the things
you discover is that back I don't know a
few hundred million years ago I don't
remember exactly how many wolfen Alpha
knows this kind of stuff
um the all the consonants that we know
today are consistent with having been in
a single lump little Pangea lump like
the Earth right now it's about
three-fifths of the surface of the Earth
is covered with ocean but the oceans are
broken up you know we have a bunch of
different oceans Atlantic Pacific things
like that we have a bunch of consonants
you know the Americas the Asia you know
things like this those are separate
continents back in the day uh according
to the sort of calculator relations
based on sort of working backwards from
existing continental drift it would be
the case that there was just a single
consonant the single Pangea consonant
it's kind of the Earth was was kind of
you know pot Land part ocean just some
land some ocean
I have to say I find this claim a little
bit suspicious I'm not sure it's right
because you know we know how consonants
are moving today we project backwards we
say how are they moving before we can
work out a certain amount from magnetic
uh alignments and rocks and things like
this but I kind of Wonder you know there
are a lot of configurations that I mean
it kind of I don't know why it would be
the case that the early Earth would have
been sort of part Land part ocean just
in in two groups like that
um perhaps there's a good reason for
that I don't know
um you know conceivably it might have
had something to do with the formation
of the Moon although I doubt it because
the Earth unlike the Moon the Moon is
very uh the Moon is not like a a kind of
a uniform uh Globe it's a of rock
um it has one part of the moon is is
really of different density than the
other parts so
um in the Earth that's not the case the
Earth is kind of a uniform
sphere of Rock with with the the gravity
of different parts of the earth is more
or less the same you know it's 9.8
meters per second per second because the
acceleration due to gravity with some
small changes in all different parts of
the Earth on the moon one part of the
moon has significantly different gravity
than the rest of the Moon because
there's a part of the Moon that has very
different density from the rest and
people believe that the in this kind of
big Splat theory of how the moon was
formed
um that there was kind of a a um
a body that collided with the Earth that
um then caused the whole earth to become
molten and a piece of of that sort of
broke off to be the moon
um and the rest kind of fell back to be
the Earth
um in that theory there's kind of the
that that has some explanation of this
kind of um uh this sort of big lump
lumpiness to the Moon
um but uh uh in terms of why should that
kind of picture have led to something
where you know half the Earth is or some
a little bit less than half the Earth is
is land and and the rest is ocean I
don't really know
um I I do wonder when you try and sort
of work backwards from from the current
thing
and you conclude oh everything could
have fit together like this maybe if you
work backwards even further the things
came apart again and there was a
different configuration that was to be
found there now in terms of what will
happen in the future I don't actually
know what the what the projection is of
what will happen I mean I know some
pieces of of um of the current
continental drift what what will happen
to them some consonants will crash into
each other some things will move apart
and so on
um and uh
I don't know what the what the end
result is
um if we looked uh you know in the earth
if left to its own devices so to speak
um you know a billion years in the
future what will the subs of the earth
look like I I should know that I I don't
know that uh one could work it out we
have the data remove from Alpha and
woven language one could one could just
do the computation but but I haven't
done it
um based on assuming that the the the
current motion of consonants continues
the same as it has been
um and that that of course raises
questions about well what produces the
kind of the the currents the flows
um in the mantle of the earth and the
liquid part of the earth that cause
these kinds of motions and I think
there's there's lots there that isn't
known in terms of can we affect content
for do we care about affecting
continental drift you know right now uh
we're worried about you know things like
sea level rise you know the sea level
over the course of geological time has
gone up and down a lot
um you know we're worried about fairly
small changes nowadays because you know
we have a lot of coastal cities and
things like that and at this point a you
know even a few meter change has at
least a big effect if you happen to have
you know an oceanfront property or
something like this
um so you know the the the the the scale
of continental drift is really very
small compared to the scale of things
they're associated with with various
kinds of sea level rise and so on so I
think the um
there isn't much motivation to say gosh
what can we do about continental drift
the only thing the only place where
that's important is when it comes to the
stick slip behavior that leads to
earthquakes and that's a place where
this idea of you know pump oil into the
San Andreas Fault in California is
something that's been talked about I
think everybody's a bit worried if you
do that you know maybe you just start
this giant chain of earthquakes and
that's um because one doesn't really
know the effect of that you know it's a
funny thing in in the way that science
works the um the models that are used
these days of that stick stop behavior
in earthquakes are actually typically
models based on things called cellular
automata and their models based on
things that I kind of worked on in the
in the early 1980s so I think I'm I
think the current models there are sort
of based on on things I did a long time
ago although I wasn't the one who did
them in the application to earthquakes
anyway a few thoughts about that
um
let's see
okay here's a question
um
various questions about chat GPT that
still seems to be in the news we're
still doing things with it it's
um uh you know the the big story there
tends to be that chat gbt is very good
at writing stuff
and the stuff might be fact it might be
fiction
um the uh there's a the sort of great
thing that can happen of chat asking
well from alpha you know questions which
one from alpha can then really factually
respond to and that becomes an
interesting way to kind of fact uh fact
enhance what GPT might otherwise be
writing about that otherwise might be
complete nonsense
but there's a question here how does
chat GPT work
all right I can I can tell you something
about that
so first of all what is chat GPT it's a
well these days it's kind of a website
made by an outfit called open AI
um
that you can type text into and you can
have a conversation you can chat with it
you can ask it um uh questions you can
ask it to write essays for you and it
does a remarkably good job of writing
very human sounding essays I think one
of the first tests I did on it was write
a persuasive essay I said uh for why
wolves are The Bluest kinds of animals
I'm not sure what I was thinking of
typing that in but the result was quite
interesting because it wrote something
that started off by saying people don't
usually think wolves are blue but in
fact there is a species of wolf that
lives in the Tibetan Plateau that is
blue and its name is this and it it's
it's blueness comes from the um uh the
same mechanism that leads to Butterfly
Wings being different colors and so on
and it went on and on and on for a bunch
of paragraphs and it's been kind of
taught to make essays like like some
high school kids are taught to make them
where there's a paragraph at the end
that says in conclusion comma Etc et
cetera Etc well
it's the things it wrote sounded really
quite convincing they were convincing
enough that I was kind of looking up on
the web is it is it actually true is
there is there in fact a blue kind of
wolf it was all complete nonsense but it
sounded very convincing and it had all
the right structure to be an essay about
blue wolves and so on
how does it work well
what what fundamentally it's doing is
it's making plausible English text and
what it's doing is you give it a prompt
a piece of initial text and it's trying
to continue that text in a plausible way
so if you say something like um uh well
in a very minimal level if it was doing
that character by character in English
if you put a q you know it's followed by
you if you put a th well there's a good
chance it's followed by an e
at a level of letters we know the
statistics the chances that different
letters follow each other in in
something like English but now we can
generalize that we can make it bigger I
was just looking if you look at um nouns
and adjectives for example uh oh gosh I
was just doing this and I'm already
forgetting the results
um but you can um uh you can say things
like if you look at typical English uh
you know you could say AI is okay that's
a you know uh and then what's the word
that comes next you know maybe the next
word is most commonly very or uh you
know or or might just be you know an for
an interesting technology or something
like this but you can ask the question
what is the typical word that follows AI
is blah and so how do you define typical
well you know there are many words in
principle in the grammar of English that
could follow but there are particular
words that we humans have typically used
when we actually write essays and write
text about things and so for example in
the case of chat GPT it took a a crawl
of the web so the web has I don't know
how many it is these days it's a few
tens of billions of pages that are
reasonably human written that exist on
the web not not that many billions
um and uh there are many more if you say
how many different possible URLs are
there there are trillions of URLs that
get used but the number of really human
written I've got a lump of text some
human wrote this the number of pages is
is not that different from the number of
humans
um not that we were all writing one page
some of us have written a lot of pages
and other people haven't been in the
business of writing web pages but it's
you know it's tens of billions of pages
is
that exist on the web and one of the
things you can crawl the web you just
start from one page and you follow all
the links on that page you follow all
the links from that page and chances are
you'll eventually get to sort of all the
pages on the web that's a good guess at
least and so for example there's a thing
called common crawl which is a project
where people have just collected have
gone and done that crawling and have you
know visited all these websites and and
repeatedly do so you can get that it's a
big big lump of stuff you can download
it from uh from various websites
um and that's that is a a copy of the
text content of the web it's a little
bit more complicated than that because a
typical modern website doesn't just have
text on it it has a bunch of JavaScript
and so on on it so you typically I think
you typically download things or walk
files which are some kind of web archive
formats and it all has to be unpacked
and you have to decide what you really
mean by the text and so on but let's
assume you've got big blobs of texts
that came from the web so you've got
that you've also got books there are
maybe some number of tens of millions of
books that have been written there are
um there are maybe five million books
that have been uh scanned maybe maybe a
little bit more than that now
um and you can scan the books you can do
optical character recognition you can
pick out the actual text in them so
that's another big Corpus material that
you can feed in and chat GPT was trained
on common crawl plus a bunch of books
and so when it says what word typically
follows this it knows that based on
having seen all of those different parts
of you know the web and these books and
so on it's like in those things and
those things that humans wrote what is
the typical thing that is the next word
okay so that's where it kind of starts
but this whole question about kind of
what is a typical piece of English it's
more than just saying give given that I
had the word is or the word you know I'm
going to have the word cat what's the
word that comes before cat might it be
black or white
um you know it's more than just word by
word kind of statistics of what's uh
what's happening more than just the
chance of what word follows which are
the word it's dealing with things on a
larger scale where it's saying when we
look at this whole flow of this sentence
or many sentences together
um what what is the typical way that we
would put these things together to to
form something which is sort of typical
of what you would see out there on the
web and so on and in fact in track GPT I
think in its current form it's really
dealing with things that are length well
2048 tokens a token is roughly a word
but sometimes there's more than one
token per word but that's the kind of
block that it's trying to say I'm trying
to make these things of this length that
are typical of what is sort of seen out
there in on on the web and by the time
you've given a prompt the the things
that can follow given that you say I
want to do this and this and this the
things that can follow are things that
are determined in many respects by The
Prompt that you gave so that's kind of
the big picture of what what it's trying
to do it's trying to mimic the sort of
typical stuff that it's seen that humans
have written out there on the web and in
books and so on and it is completely
remarkable as far as I'm concerned that
anything like that is as good at
producing sort of interesting essay type
text or poetry or whatever else as it is
it's remarkable it's something that I
think we is really a big clue in terms
of the way that we should think about
processes about human thinking and the
nature of meaning and text and and all
this kind of thing nobody knew that this
was going to work this well and in fact
sort of the precursors to modern chat
gbt didn't work as nearly this well
now there are there are lots of things
so so in terms of how does it actually
work that that's the big picture of what
it's trying to do mechanically how does
it do that I can tell you something
about that but uh just to talk a little
bit more about sort of the construction
of what's going on when we make an
English sentence we are partly we do it
according to the grammatical rules that
exist in English like we might say uh
you know
um
the uh what's a good example my gosh
the uh the crocodile ate the what do
crocodiles eat the fish
um and uh the um
and then
you know that has a as a structure of an
English sentence the crocodile that's a
noun phrase eight that's a verb the fish
that's another noun phrase
um and so we know that English is set up
grammatically in as something that says
that that has the form of things like
noun a subject noun followed by a verb
followed by an object noun and so on
that is the grammatical structure now of
course we can have sentences that mean
absolutely nothing we say uh the moon
you know fished
the elephant or something
it doesn't mean anything what does that
mean it's so we can have even more
meaningless sentences we can say uh
uh I don't know the uh we can say things
which are which whether where the
categories of thing that we put together
don't really fit in addition to things
that don't make sense because they're
not sort of physically possible they're
also things where the category of thing
isn't really right you could say
something like uh you know the house
eight
the lettuce
well houses don't eat things and it's
sort of or you could say the um
uh
you know the chair was happy
chairs don't have feelings so far as We
Know
um it's uh there there are all these
ways that sentences can be grammatically
correct in terms of their syntax in
terms of you know the parts of speech
and so on but they're not semantically
correct they don't have meanings that we
can immediately identify now you know in
if you're writing a poem it's a little
different a chair could be happy and a
poem because poems are a more elaborate
kind of more abstracted form of
communication than ordinary text but
this question of what fits semantically
together is an interesting question that
we really know very little about and
chat GPT is kind of showing us that
there is probably a way of thinking
about sort of what fits semantically
together just like there's a way of
thinking about what fits syntactically
together with parts of speech and nouns
and verbs and and grammars and so on and
and so that there's you know I think
it's a it's a kind of a very intro
interesting kind of wake-up call for the
analysis of kind of how meanings get
constructed and how how that works it's
interesting that you know I've been
interested in this stuff for a long time
and I I've actually been sort of shocked
recently I I you know what's been
studied about this and I I've certainly
known things that have been studied in
in the last few hundred years and I kind
of recently realized that most of what's
talked about actually goes back to
Aristotle from more than two thousand
years ago talking about kind of the way
that you construct things with meaning
and he had a very sort of primitive way
of thinking about that he also had a
very different view of kind of how the
world is put together and how one could
talk about things using science and so
on and it's time for a rewrite a reboot
of that and that's a project I'm I'm
hoping to do fairly soon
um but in any case let's come back to
the mechanics of how track GPT works
okay so it's it's got text as a prompt
it's trying to continue that text in a
statistically reasonable way okay how
does it actually do that
well
the uh the thing it's doing is it's
training a neural network
to uh to figure out how to do that let
me explain how that roughly works
so a neural net is kind of modeled on
the theory that we've had for the last
well kind of 100 years or so about how
brains work that brains have these
neurons and neurons can be either like
uh that they they can be you know active
or not active electrically doing
something or not doing something every
millisecond every every thousand
thousand times a second roughly neurons
are like oh am I am I am I going to fire
and generate an electrical impulse or
not and a typical neuron might have a
thousand connections to other neurons
that'll little dendrites little little
uh tentacles that sort of stick out in
these nerve cells and in our brains we
have maybe 100 billion nerve cells and
human brains
um and uh each one might have a thousand
connections to other nerve cells and so
the the idea is that when we think
what's happening is that there is
electrical activity one nerve cell it's
kind of spreading its activity to other
nerve cells spreading to other ones and
that's producing this kind of whole
pattern of electrical activity in our
brains that corresponds to our process
of thinking and we think that memory has
to do with the way that there are the
connections between nerve cells the
synapses the connections between the the
the the the den the the things that
stick out of the bodies of the nerve
cells the ways that those can be uh
whether those connections exist whether
they don't exist whether they're strong
connections whether they're weak
connections we think that memory and
learning has to do with the making of
those connections there are different
ideas and detail about how those
connections get strengthened and made
and what produces that that process of
learning and roughly you know we we have
sort of a short-term memory that works
for a few minutes and then gradually
over the course of of a day or so will
form a long-term memory and there's
there's actual protein synthesis that
happens and so on there
um there's even you know very recent
theories about how there are kind of
dark synapses that have been kind of
lying around waiting to be activated
um and uh and then sort of come up come
come to be active when we when we form
memories and so on there's there's some
uncertainty about how that all works but
roughly the idea is there are all these
all these nerve cells all these neurons
they have lots of connections to lots of
other nerve cells and there's something
to do with the the weights of the
connections that encodes the memories
and when we think when we use our brains
what's happening is that neurons
activity from one neuron is spreading to
others through these kind of connections
through these synapses and so on and so
artificial neural Nets are modeled on
the same kind of idea except then
instead of being actual nerve cells
there's just uh things in computer
memory um where it's uh we just have or
in more from language it's just a uh
just some piece of some some uh
expression in more from language that
represents
um every uh sort of every one of these
nerve cells and represents sort of the
value of that nerve cell and then there
are weights by which this nerve cell is
kind of how much effect does one nerve
cell have on another nerve cell so you
end up with these um
uh with these big I mean mathematically
it's matrices or tensors which say I've
got this whole Vector of values this
whole sequence of values and I'm going
to determine from that a new sequence of
values and roughly what ends up
happening is you add up you say this is
the input sequence of values I'm going
to take some sum I'm going to weight
those values in different ways I'm going
to add them all up and then there's kind
of a thing where in addition to just
adding the numbers up you have some kind
of threshold the most common thing
that's done in current neural Nets I
think called relu which is actually a
very simple thing it's just if the the
weights where you add up all these
numbers can be either positive or
negative if it's if the resulting added
up thing is negative it's zero otherwise
it's just the value that you got that's
a simple way to to do this sort of
thresholding effect
um in in actual brains it probably works
a bit differently but that's kind of the
basic idea so the way it works is in an
artificial neural lesson probably in an
actual neural net in our brains they're
the succession of layers and you're kind
of you're saying oh we we give this
collection of activity to the first
layer then it does this transformation
it produces a collection of activity for
the next layer keeps on going layer by
layer up through the through the system
and eventually gets to the output
now
a question is uh and okay and so then
the issue is well okay what should all
those weights be that go from the input
to the output and so then you want to
construct different kinds of functions
that you can compute so for example one
thing might be on the first layer you're
giving a bunch of values that correspond
to pixel values from an image and what
you want is it goes through the network
many layers you know
50 layers or something and out at the
end you should have something where in
the output there's 2 000 possibilities
um that correspond to sort of a thing
with two thousand possible values and
one of those values let's say is going
to be big and most of the other are
going to be small the big and those two
thousand things you should say they
correspond to two thousand kinds of
objects that might exist in the world
cats and dogs and elephants and chairs
and tables and so on each one of those
things corresponds to one of those
objects and what you want is a is a
process where you give a bunch of pixels
in you go through 50 layers and then at
the end the last layer has as output
something where most of the values are
close to zero except there's a high
value for a few things and it's like
okay that corresponds to a picture of a
cat
so what you're trying to do is you're
trying to in that particular case for a
neural that's trying to identify images
what you're trying to do is say it
starts off with a bunch of pixel values
red green blue is this for this pixel
you know 10 million pixel values or a
million pixel values or whatever for an
image and then it's like go through
these 50 layers going through all of
these things where you've got all these
weights and so on you might have 10
million weights or something you know in
different arranged between these
different layers and eventually out at
the other end you're going to get
something where you have a sequence of
values and where they're mostly zero
except for the ones that correspond to
the things that it thought it saw okay
so the big question now is how do you
set up all those weights so that the
neural net actually behaves this way
and so that is where you have to train
the neural net how do you train the
neural net well you might start up by
just having completely random weights
and then you feed in an image of a cat
and it says oh that's half elephant and
half turtle or something and it's like
oh that's not right okay how do you
improve it well
you say that's not right that's pretty
far away from what is right there's a
what's usually called a loss function
it's like how far away from being right
are you and what you try to do is you
say okay you're pretty far away from
being right but if you just change those
values in this direction you'd be
getting closer to being right
and so then what you have to do is say
this is what we know in the output
you've got an elephant and a turtle but
you really just wanted it to be a cat so
that means the elephant and turtle
values are big but you really wanted the
cat value to be big so you can think
about that as the numbers for elephant
and turtles should be get smaller the
numbers for cat should get bigger that
provides you kind of a way to say these
are the these are the way I should
change the numbers in the output
so now the question is well how do you
change the weights and the inside of the
neural net to uh to get you closer to
the numbers that you want in the output
okay so this is a giant application of
calculus
um and it's it's sort of interesting
because there are many things in the
world where sort of calculus uh became
less and less useful and and gave way to
a lot of things that were much more
about programs and so on this is one
place where Calculus is still really
useful because what happens is you're
you're making use of well maybe I don't
want to go into the technical details of
this but it's in the end it's making use
of the chain rule in calculus operating
on you know in calculus you might study
a function of you know one variable two
variables three variables in neural Nets
we're dealing with functions of millions
of variables
um and what you're trying to do is
you're trying to say okay you want to
back propagate you want to propagate
backwards from from the way you want to
change the output what do you want to do
to these weights in the middle so that
it if you were fed that input again
you'll be closer to getting the output
you want
so what happens is you bash these neural
Nets really hard you do you know
trillion times you do this process of
saying hey what does this input give us
output
um and oh that's not quite right it has
you need to push it in this Direction
Let's propagate back from how we needed
to push it let's get these weights
changed in the middle and you keep doing
that you do it over and over and over
again and eventually the thing learns in
the sense that the weights that are
arranged in the middle actually do do
the thing you want so the most common
form of training well in in this setup
is so-called supervised training where
you say here's a picture it's a cat
here's a picture it's a dog
and you do that in typical image
identification training uh in the early
days of this when used like 25 million
images of a total of maybe 5 000 kinds
of objects
and so what you do is you keep on saying
oh here's this here's the picture of a
cat
um uh you know you should say it's a cat
oh you're saying it's an elephant push
in this direction
Etc et cetera saying just keep doing
that over and over again nobody knew how
hard it would be to do this there's a
big Discovery in 2011 that it was
possible to do this people didn't know
it you know it was a month of CPU time
somebody left something just running and
at the end of it it turned out it had
managed to learn a bunch of things
nobody knew that was going to work
nobody knew how hard it would be to sort
of bash the neural net to be able to
learn these things
but in any case that worked and the
thing that that happens so so there are
many many tricks in how you actually do
this training and you know for example
you might not have enough images you
could synthetically make images say well
this is a cat but we want to add to the
cat image something where we just change
the pixels around a bit and it's still a
cat and then we use that as another
piece of the training you know in some
places where people are for example
let's say training self-driving cars to
recognize different kinds of objects and
so on there's a certain amount of data
you get from just driving cars around or
having your fleet of cars from some car
manufacturer that's kind of going around
and seeing what it sees on the streets
and getting all that data back and using
that to do more training but in the end
there might not be enough training data
and in the end I think what's been done
there is people make essentially video
games for the cars to drive in
artificially
um and that's kind of the way that so
they're they're kind of driving around
millions and millions of hours of um of
sort of synthesized uh experience on
roads and and so that but but that's a
typical example of kind of this this
sort of mechanism for training where you
say this is what I want to to this is
what I'm going to feed in this is what I
want to get out now learn in the middle
of the neural Nets to do that
okay so
in the case of of chatri PT the thing we
want to do is we want to say
um here's a piece of English text it's a
big long piece of I don't know you know
you got it out of off some random web
page or it came from Shakespeare or
whatever else it was it's a piece of
English text now you say Let Me Show You
neural net the first 10 words of that
text and I want your the neural Nets to
arrange itself so that it will correctly
tell me the 11th word the 12th word et
cetera et cetera et cetera okay so
that's that's the task that you're
training the thing on so what you want
to do is kind of bash the neural net you
want to run that enough times with
enough different pieces of text and and
sort of bash them on that hard enough
that it will eventually learn correctly
to predict and you can say to the neural
that oh you got the wrong word there you
know let's poke you in this direction
and um uh and then
uh then you'll get a different you know
that then you'll you'll get closer to
the word you should have got based on
the training of the actual text that
you're you're shown now the the the
whole point the thing that's exciting
with something like chat GPT or with
so-called generative AI in general is
that it is often being given inputs that
it's never seen before let me give the
example of a cat and dog identifier
first
so let's say you show it a very specific
photograph of a cat
then you could imagine you're going to
train it to say okay that specific
photograph of a cat it's a cat
but now let's say you modify that cat a
bit the cat has been uh you know I don't
know licking its whiskers or something
or whatever whatever although the cat
has its ear in a different orientation
or the cat is on a different background
or the cat is uh you know put its pore
up in some way you still want to
recognize it as a cat and the big point
about these neural Nets and so on is
that after you've trained in enough of
cat images it kind of gets the idea of
roughly what a cat image is and so even
if the cat had its pore up it can still
say oh that's a cat
okay so the the point with chat GPT is
that it's saying if there's a particular
piece of English then or text and it
could know yes that is exactly how it
should continue it's a famous you know
to be or not to be that is the question
you know whether it is noble and
whatever you know the the Shakespeare
speech right it could know exactly what
the next word is in that Shakespeare
speech but what if you gave it something
that had never seen before it's gonna
it's gonna try and generate something
that is reasonable to generate but it's
never seen that particular input before
and the thing it's going to generate is
something that's never been seen before
as well
so I will say by the way one thing uh
that is important in chat GPT is that
sometimes it's like I've seen it before
I know exactly how to continue it
turns out that that doesn't produce very
good results so what's done in chat GPT
is it has what's called the temperature
where it knows the most likely way that
this is going to continue is blah but
actually it knows the top five ways it
might continue and instead of always
picking the most likely way to continue
it it has a little Randomness that's
sometimes picking the less likely way to
continue and so that's that's a an
important piece of the sort of the
creativity of something like chat GPT I
think it's parameters I think it's set
to 0.8
um sort of the the um the the I'm
certain I'm going to pick the top thing
will be one so it has a little bit of
uncertainty there and that's important
and if you give it no uncertainty at
least the earlier versions of things
like the the earlier
um GPT
systems if you give it no uncertainty if
you say always pick the Top Choice it
very often gets in a loop and it'll just
keep saying the same thing the same
sequence of words over and over again
the thing that's totally bizarre is that
in the end what chat GPT is doing is
it's adding one word at a time basically
even just sometimes one token one piece
of a word at a time and it's producing
this essay that seems like oh it makes
perfect sense the whole essay makes
sense but yet the way it actually worked
was just it's adding one word at a time
and that's really telling us something
about sort of the structure of of text
and and things like this well
okay how does it actually do the adding
one word at a time the uh uh okay let's
see
um the thing there is an idea that
things called Transformer Nets okay so
the the thing I was telling you about
for example an image
um when you have this image and you've
got these sort of artificial neurons and
they're connected to other artificial
neurons you're kind of flowing through
layer by layer
um typically for an image the the sort
of the neurons are the artificial
neurons are arranged in kind of an array
that corresponds to the the geometry
let's say two-dimensional geometry of
the image
um those are usually often called
convenience convolutional neural
networks that are arranged in this kind
of geometrical way actually very similar
to these cellular automata that I've
long studied
um but any case the the way that works
is
um it has these layers of neural of
artificial neurons you go from one to
the next and so on okay so there's a
slightly different idea that's used when
you're generating sequences when when
there's a as I say for for dealing with
images you you start off with your first
layers of of artificial neurons are
arranged in a grid just like the pixels
in the image actually it's very similar
to our visual cortex our primary visual
cortex at the back of our brains also
has neurons that are arranged in a way
that somehow corresponds to the way that
the cells on a retina are arranged in in
that kind of geometrical structure okay
but but so in
when you're generating a sequence
the the idea is that you'll have
something where essentially the thing
you feed into the neural net is
something that is going to be you're
trying to add to the sequence and what
you're doing is you're looking back in
the previous things that are already in
the sequence and you're taking the
things that are already in the sequence
and you're saying okay which numbered
things in that sequence should I look at
to feed into my neural Nets that works
out what the next thing should be so the
the typical thing the so-called
attention mechanism is you're you're
trying to add the next word so you're
going to look back and you're going to
say the word five ago that was important
that was a verb or something that was
important the verb the word 15 ago that
was also important that was some subject
of a sentence or something like that so
one of the things you try to do is to
learn sort of which word is worth
looking at in these in in the kind of
preceding part of the text that's kind
of the attention mechanism then what you
do is what you're basically doing is
given a set of words you're figuring out
which words are important then you're
feeding those words into something which
is very much the same kind of neural net
that I just described where you're just
saying there's this uh that there's
you're going to feed it in and then it's
going to produce okay your okay I got to
explain a couple of other things to to
make this make sense okay first point is
you are
uh what starts off as a bunch of words
the cat sat on the mat
okay what neural Nets deal with are
numbers basically uh collections of
numbers and you know is it 5.7 is it 5.8
Etc et cetera et cetera so how do you
turn the cats out on the mat into a
bunch of numbers
so in a first approximation you just say
Okay V is word number one cat is word
number 714 sat is word number such and
such you essentially just make up
numbers for words
okay turns out that the thing that is
really useful to do is to make up not
just individual numbers for words but
for every word you have a whole
collection of numbers I think in chat
GPT it is
16 000 numbers per word I'm not sure of
that order it used to be maybe a
thousand numbers per word but it's the
the these are okay so what that is is
for every word you're saying I'm going
to characterize this word by saying it's
0.7 2.2 4.6 minus 0.8 Etc et cetera et
cetera thousands of numbers
okay what do those numbers mean well
those numbers are some kind of way of of
saying what the meaning of the word is
let me give an example
so let's say you're going to let's take
an example not with words let's say it's
with flags
flags of the world or something you want
to arrange the flags of the world on a
piece of paper so that flags that are
similar looking will be in the same
place on a piece of paper so I don't
know the um the French flag and the
Italian flag they I think they're
similar
um they you know they'll be in a similar
place the um uh the uh maybe the um
oh I'm I'm doing badly here on my Flags
but um uh you know some country that has
a big green flag is is really in a
different place from you know the US
which has a you know red white and blue
flag things like this and the you know
the the the the flag of the you know the
U.S flag might be a bit similar to the
UK flag
um I just you know how what which one is
visually similar to what so you're
trying to arrange these on a piece of
paper according to visual similarity and
so what you can then say is if you've
done that successfully actually we could
we could forget Flags we just do letters
of the alphabet so lowercase letters
they Alpha get printed like an a is
similar to a g a v is similar to a y
things like that we arrange those in
similar places on the on the page and
more from language there's a function
called feature space plot that does
exactly this that will take a bunch of
things and try and arrange them
according to their features in some ways
so that things which have similar
features are nearby Okay so so the
result of that is that you can take
anything like it's a v it's a y it's a
it's an American flag whatever it is and
you can place it somewhere in this
feature space and it'll have some
coordinates it'll be some position it'll
be you know x coordinate this y
coordinate that and so the point is that
you try and arrange it so that the
things that are that are that are
similar in some sense have nearby
coordinates they appear nearby and this
feature space plot now in in the real
case you're doing that not in two
Dimensions but in many thousands of
Dimensions but anyway the result is
you're trying to get these things where
every word is encoded by this array of
numbers so that words that have similar
meaning are encoded with similar
collections of numbers that's usually
called an embedding word embedding it's
sort of the way that you embed words in
let's say thousand-dimensional space
um and those embeddings those learned
embeddings that you you deduce from
looking at so so the way you learn these
embeddings is to for example say uh this
word appears uh you know okay so words
like for colors for example might be
somewhat nearby in the embedding and you
can tell that because if you look at
tons of text you can substitute red for
blue in different places so there's a
sort of a framework for the sentence
where could be a red could be a blue
there we kind of know that those things
red and blue have to be somewhat similar
because they get they get arranged in
the same places and in sentences
um and so that sort of tells us
something about their similarity of
meaning you could swap crocodile for
alligator because they appear in similar
sentences and so crocodile and alligator
will be near in meaning space so that's
the way that you deduce these embeddings
these mappings from words to collections
of thousand numbers and so on those
embeddings are valuable things that's
actually something that people nowadays
sell embeddings
um because they what is it good of
having an embedding well it means that
if you've got a sentence for example and
well in the end you can do these
embeddings not just for words but for
sentences and you say I want to do a
search I want to find is there somewhere
in my documents where I have a sentence
that's like the sentence that I have now
well if you could just take every
sentence in the document and turn it
into this Vector of numbers this is a
collection of numbers and say are these
numbers close then that will tell you do
you have a sentence somewhere in a
document that's close to the one that
you're looking for
okay so there are a bunch of tricks in
in the case of chat GPT
um there are a bunch of tricks that are
used so for example you can say well the
words come in a sequence
um uh you know
um the cat sat on the mat uh it's kind
of inconvenient to have those words be
actually arranged the cat sat on the mat
rather there's a positional encoding so
that you basically include with the V
you include in that big Vector you
include information that says oh that
was the first word the next one that was
the second word it's kind of a weird
little positional tag that gets included
so that allows you to take all those
words and basically put them in a big
vat they're just a bunch of words bunch
of vectors that correspond to these
words just put them in this vat then
you use this attention mechanism to
decide which of these words you are
going to sort of arrange in what order
and how much weight you're going to put
on each one then you feed that into this
neural net then you get out the sort of
prediction for the next word now okay of
course it's actually more complicated
than this there are like the typical
thing that's happening is for every word
you're going through many iterations of
this attention feed forward it's called
feed forward when you when you have this
um this thing which just sort of feeds
through a neural network you're doing I
think it's 16 layers maybe maybe it's
more than that in chat GPT
um some number of tens of iterations of
that process now that's what what
happens when you're trying to when
you're running chat GPT and it's trying
to figure out the next word when you're
training it you have to do sort of the
whole thing kind of in reverse and you
have to kind of feed it you have to say
well what do you think you know GPT what
do you think the next word is oh no no
you're wrong let's tell you a different
word instead okay so that that's that's
the main part of the training is that
there's an additional part of the
training which is tricky and which is
actually one of the things that really I
think has has separated chat GPT from
the previous generations of so-called
large language models things which are
sort of models of of how text is
generated
um the uh but let me uh well okay so so
the the first step is sort of the the
main training of the thing so I think in
chat GPT it's it's um using an
underlying language model that has about
175 billion parameters so over the
course of you know CPU years GPU years
more more to the point
um you are sort of gradually refining
those 175 billion parameters to
represent the statistical
characteristics of all of those billions
of pages on the web and millions of of
books and all this kind of thing those
175 billion parameters encode the kind
of the information of what is typical
text like that you see out there on the
web and so on now that's to be compared
and our brains maybe we have a few
trillion synapses between our neurons so
the number of parameters in in chat GPT
is not that different from the number in
a brain although it knows about a lot of
stuff that is much more obscure than
even people like me know about
um you know who have decent human
memories
um I think the the and there are a lot
of tricky issues about
um you know is it really does it really
need uh precise numbers 0.2785644
et cetera et cetera et cetera that
really doesn't matter
um I think I don't know how many chat
apt is using but it's probably just
using about 255 levels
um for each number rather than having a
precise number that can be any number of
digits
Okay so
uh that that's the basic thing is
there's this whole attention mechanism
and you're you're you know it's trying
to continue the text okay it's another
important piece which is so-called
reinforcement training reinforcement
learning applied to chat gbt so people
ran these chat Bots and it's like well
what's the chatbot going to produce well
sometimes the chatbot produces crazy
stuff it's off yakking about you know
just gone completely Bonkers it's it's
uh it's it's off the deep end in some
way
um and so what was done was that people
were told you know have a chat with this
chat bot and rate it tell it well you're
off the deep end is it going in the
wrong direction oh no no that's great
that's bad that's great Etc et cetera et
cetera so groups of people actually did
this and turns out that's a very
powerful it turns out it's again not so
obvious that that's a powerful thing for
directing what the output will really
look like I think there's probably also
a certain amount of templating that's
been done for particular kinds of you
know make a poem make a make an essay
things like that that's sort of just
engineering on top of on top of other
things just to make a a better user
experience for the system but the thing
that that is sort of important is that
you have these groups of people and
they're like telling it do this do that
and that's then fed into this
um uh
uh that that's that's fed into the kind
of training of the neural net there's a
there's an additional layer that is this
reinforcement training that kind of
keeps it more or less on track that
seems to be important people can
obviously can obviously be very
controversial to say well you know
you've had some group of people that are
training it that are really keen on you
know I don't know what the the critical
character of uh you know why
I don't know that are really keen on on
this feature of the world or that
feature of the world or or their they're
really big on promoting the you know the
rights of cats over dogs or whatever
else it is and so that set of people
that did that final training independent
of of just feeding in the big pile of
stuff from the web the people who did
the final training have a lot more
control over it's gonna like cats not
dogs
um and so that's sort of an issue and
there's there's kind of a bunch of
questions about how that should be done
and what this new generation of kind of
AI Wranglers
um you know how one sort of gets the
right groups of people and how one sort
of stops things in in the right way
there but that's a that's sort of a
different issue but but that's the
that's the basic idea so I think I I
think I more or less went through kind
of how how chat GPT works and what it's
always doing is it's generating a word
at a time sometimes it's sub word and
you can see that it makes up words
because it has tokens that are not quite
a whole word and so it can end up gluing
together those two tokens to make up a
word that's never been seen before and
so
it is uh uh yeah so so it's doing this
everything it's doing it's taking the
prompt the original prompt it's saying
what's the next token what's the next
word it's giving you that it's taking
the prompt plus the token feeding that
back as as another thing and saying okay
now continue that and it keeps doing
that over and over again until you get
your complete object out and I think as
I say it can it can go about 2048 steps
doing that that that's the distance back
that it's kind of a tension system looks
um to make to keep coherence in the text
so you know if it was talking at Blue
Wolves At the beginning if you ask it to
go too long it'll be talking about uh
you know orange you know Elephants or
something at the end and it will have
completely lost the thread of what it
was talking about because it only has
sort of a finite look back
um that's that's how far the training
could be it could be made to work
um
that's uh
okay well anyway so that was a basic
explanation actually that went better
than I thought it might go I thought I
might get dragged into a bunch of deep
technicality that that um I think I
managed to to skirt around there
um
let's see
uh
so Brady is asking could you say that
chat gbd is made a graph of the space of
words or ideas yes simplicitly it has
it's not so much a graph it's more just
placing things in in you know on a piece
of paper or something except it's a
thousand-dimensional piece of paper
um uh to to say how things are related
to each other it's more so than you
could you could take that Arrangement
and you could say okay let me join the
nearest neighbors for example
um and uh then you would make a graph
out of those things but um but it
doesn't it start off with a graph
um
let's see
uh
F no ARP is asking saying I'd like to
see if thesaurus based on vectors and
semantic space so you could give it a
word and ask it a word close in meaning
but heading in a certain direction yes
interesting idea people have tried to do
some of that
um I don't think it's properly developed
yet but it's something we will certainly
see more of
um I think that sort of the writing
assistant idea you know thesaurus you
know people like Roger in the 1850s or
whatever came up with this idea of Let's
Make a thesaurus where we group words
together by similarity of meaning so
um you know if you're saying well I
can't quite remember that word for you
know Aficionado I can't quite remember
Aficionado or something and but I know
some similar words you kind of look up
the similar word in the thesaurus and
it's going to give you the word
Aficionado
um and uh you can imagine doing that by
saying well I've I remember this word
give me words that are close in meaning
space
now this idea of meaning space is kind
of interesting because there are words
that have many meanings
um same word in English but it has ended
up having many meanings sometimes those
meanings used to be uh you know together
like a site for example s-i-t-e
um you know that used to mean you know a
building site or something like that now
it's you know as it's often means a
website and originally the word site was
just sort of a place where you put
things and it had one meaning but now I
would say that you've really broken off
the building site and the website
meaning have really separated
historically
um linguistically and so that's a place
where if you looked at sort of the
history of the meaning space the the
evolution of meaning space the word
sight would split in two in terms of
where where it where it ends up in
meaning space and so some words some
words also come because it just happens
two words a very different origin just
happened to to be you know the same word
that gets spelled the same way and
they're kind of uh and they again are in
different places in meaning space
so
you can imagine like saying take a word
like site for example and um uh and try
and say where in meaning space are the
typical uses of that word and what you
see in we've done some experiments on
this you see the different meanings of a
single word sort of breakup and meaning
space you can kind of see that happening
and so yes you can imagine this kind of
this kind of space of what we mean by
things being this thing now now it's a
little tricky because people sometimes
say oh it's a space you know it's like
you can place things here and you make a
line from here to there and you can keep
going in that direction so a very famous
example is that the line that goes from
King to Queen
um
oh no I'm forgetting the well okay the
line that goes from from man to woman in
meaning space is in a certain direction
now let's take that direction and let's
start with the word King and say let's
go in the same direction what do we get
to oh we get to Queen
doesn't really work that well and and it
doesn't work that well because
the meaning space is undoubtedly not
space like we used to with coordinates
and it just moves around and you know
we're adding values to coordinates and
things like that almost certainly
meaning space is something much more
complicated it kind of reminds us of the
of our physics project and the actual
very low level structure of physical
space is also more complicated it only
is something which emerges as something
that seems like roughly
three-dimensional space to observers
like us who are operating on a scale
very large compared to the underlying
atoms of space
so the question of what the analogous
kind of overall structure of meaning
space is it's very interesting question
I don't think anybody has any idea what
the answer is yet maybe I'll try and
work on it and figure it out but um the
uh uh but but at the level you know you
might think directions in meaning space
are meaningful I don't think they're
that meaningful because I think the
space just isn't of the type where it's
not a linear enough thing it's not a
euclidean enough space that you can
really identify those directions in that
kind of way it's something more
complicated perhaps more like the kind
of graph structures that we think are
underneath this kind of network
structure that we think exists in
physical space if you go down a trillion
trillion trillion trillionth of a meter
um in in physical space
uh but yes that's an interesting thing
um
okay Jamie is asking how well does chat
GPT handle slang or figures of speech
does it understand text as literal is it
capable of picking up these notes you
know nobody really knows what it can do
and what it can't do you have to just go
try it I mean basically if it's seen
that before it's it's often shocking in
what it can figure out and sometimes
shocking what it can't figure out you
know people are surprised oh it can't do
arithmetic well it has no computation
capability it's just saying does it
sound right so to speak in fact the way
it deals with numbers it has these
tokens the current to actually be T I
think takes numbers with digits in
groups of three it kind of treats them
like pieces of words and it's like you
go try and figure out how to do long
multiplication with numbers where you're
just remembering how groups of three
digits work it's hopeless
but that's not what track GPT is about
it's about the statistical continuation
of text it's very different use of
computation from the one that for
example wolf now for a Wilson language
is doing where we're really what we try
to do there is to have a precise
representation we might be talking about
the same kinds of things that the text
in chat GPT is talking about we might be
talking about cats and dogs and
elephants and alligators and this and
that but for us those aren't just words
somewhere in meaning space those are
things that we can compute definite
things from you know if we have a city I
don't know London or something like that
for us that's a thing with a particular
location geolocation on the earth with
these values and so on we can compute if
we want to know how do we go from London
to New York how far is it we're
Computing based on the shape of the
earth and so on we're using you know
elliptic integrals or whatever you need
to use to compute that distance and so
on to figure out figure those things
things out that's a completely different
kind of use of computation from the one
that chatgpt is doing where it's just
saying does this sound right does this
sound like something I've seen before
it's it's kind of I think the
distinction between sort of the way that
people typically thought about thinking
before the 1600s when really
mathematical ideas about kind of the way
that physics and so on work came in
before that time people were like well
let's just think it through by pure
thought after that time it's more like
well we can actually have the systematic
formal abstract system where we can
compute things and where we can build
this big tower of computation that's the
tradition that well from language and
wolf malver and so on live in it's a
different tradition than the chat gbt
one which is one that's really much more
based on the kind of pure human thought
type thing pure human does it sound
right you know I have to say as I make
up sentences and I go yak yak yak here I
I feel a little bit like this chat GPT
system in some sense because I'm you
know I don't believe that these
sentences are constructed kind of that I
have in my mind as I begin to say a
sentence that I have in my mind the
whole thing constructed by a computation
I think it is more this kind of thing
where I'm I'm kind of I've got some
basic idea and I'm following a direction
and then my brain My Language Center in
my brain is just producing more and more
stuff sort of following that direction
uh using the one something that is sort
of an iterative process of of the kind
I've described for to a chat GPT
but
so you know there are things where
you'll see uh interesting analogies that
it makes that came probably because
statistically well maybe it had just
read that analogy before or maybe and
this is something that will probably
happen when you have later generations
of this kind of Technology it will see
that there's an analogy this way of
thinking about things relates to this
way of thinking about this kind of thing
is has the same pattern of thinking the
same pattern of talking about it as this
as a way of talking about something
completely different so you'll see these
remarkable analogies that it will make
doesn't happen quite this way yet but I
think it will these remarkable analogies
oh this thing that's in economics can be
applied to biology over here because the
pattern of thinking the pattern of
talking about these things is similar
even though sort of the words are
different that's something that I think
will be kind of a wow
um for the future for these kinds of
systems
uh
let's see so William comments could it
be the chat GPT isn't training it's
training is text rather than the real
world should it use real world data such
as sensory information of Sight and
Sound and all those kinds of things yeah
I mean you know one of the next things
that's coming is video generation and
video generation is a bit more physicsy
I mean in text we can yak about anything
we want you know we can make up all
kinds of words and poetry and all sorts
of other things
um that um uh are just
um
uh you know just just words that
arranged however we arranged them when
we make a video we're not synthesizing
typically every pixel in that video
we're taking that video somehow usually
from the physical world and the physical
world has physical has laws of physics
that determine you know we we drop this
book it's going to fall in this way and
all the pixels in the book are going to
fall in this way so yes I think training
from sort of the real world in videos
for example is an interesting thing and
implicitly the system will learn the
laws of physics and whether these kinds
of you know attention layers and and
Transformers and things maybe they'll
even be useful and maybe they're for for
learning physics like laws uh you know
if you've shown it you know a bunch of
videos and then you say okay extrapolate
I want to know how a spinning black hole
works it's not going to work
um it's going to make the same mistakes
that we humans make because we have been
trained by seeing everyday physics and
we don't know based on everyday physics
how something totally bizarre that's
never been that that you know doesn't
really follow everyday physics even
though it might follow the same
underlying laws of physics how that
works
um all right I think I'm supposed to go
back to my day job here and I see some
other interesting questions
um
uh
uh let's see maybe I'll just see if
there are any others about
um about chat GPD specifically and then
um
uh
it's a question from skeptic here with
all new AI tools what do you think will
be the effect on truth and facts as we
know them you know I gotta believe
people are going to care more about
facts and actually it's pretty good for
people like me you know I've spent
basically my my my whole life building
this kind of computational language to
represent things in a kind of precise
formal factual uh buildable on solidly
buildable on way and I have to believe
that the value of that is only going to
go up as a result of the ability to
basically produce things that kind of
sound right but aren't so for example if
you have a scientific paper you can now
easily synthesize a scientific paper
about for example blue wolves which you
know might very well pass muster if you
feed it to humans you say You're
supposed to review this paper is it is
it you know is it valid oh it sounds
perfectly right it's talking about the
blue wolf and it's got this and that and
the other and it's it's citing it's
making yeah one of the things I find
really fun with chat GPT is it will cite
sources it will say according to the uh
you know
Madagascar Department of geology blah
blah blah blah blah
well actually there isn't a Madagascar
Department of geology or maybe there is
but I don't think there is
um the uh
I just made it up it made up something
plausible that is statistically
plausible but it's just not real in the
actual world as it is
um I think that now obviously if it was
writing fiction you know it's all good
if it's trying to write things that are
factual it's a it's a big lose but it
means that you know you write the
scientific paper it's citing all these
sources it's got all these things it's
got these Latin names but it's all
nonsense it's just pure Fiction made up
to be plausible but not real well if you
actually want to do science and build on
that and so on well you need a a solid
foundation there where things can be
real and our computational language is I
think the best way to have sort of a a
broad solid foundation so you say oh
there's this statement in this in this
thing or there's this picture that got
synthesized you know I didn't talk about
image generation but that's a whole
nother another area
um I haven't actually seen too many
scientific paper images that are
generated by generative AI but that's
certainly something you could do and
it'll make some lovely plots that's
complete nonsense
um but you know if what you say is well
I want to see the computational language
that was behind that plot you click it
okay there's a piece of language code
it's a precise computational thing it's
a precise piece of notation a bit like
math notation it's something precise and
computational or you can go run it on a
computer and oh by golly it actually
produces the picture I can read the code
I as a human can read that wolfen
language code and see what it says I can
understand what that sort of
computational idea is from that piece of
code I think that there's there's going
to be one will see increasing value to
that kind of notion of what's the
computational language behind just the
words words words words words words
um you know I think that's a that's a
sort of a thing that will be will be
noticeable
um you know what what are the kind of
formal taggings of these things that are
just said with words it has been the
case that by the time somebody it's it's
it has been a good heuristic that by the
the time you see a beautifully written
explanation of something it's probably
sensible that's been a good thing to
guess in the past Because by the time
somebody went to the trouble and was
kind of had their act together enough to
write that beautiful Exposition that
beautiful Exposition they probably you
know they probably also put effort into
making sure the expedition was correct
but now the cost of making a beautiful
sounding Exposition just went close to
zero and so you can have a beautiful
exposition of complete nonsense and so
you know the the heuristic changes you
know if you see something that's
beautifully written you no longer assume
somebody actually bothered to work out
whether it was right it could be just
complete nonsense so you kind of shift
the the way you look for kind of the uh
um you know where you look for you know
is this nonsense or not from the
heuristic of is it well written did you
know did somebody go to the trouble of
writing it you have to show shifted
somewhere else and I think computational
language is as far as I can see really
the only place we have to shift that to
and that's some so I think that's a
that's a thing that um you know happens
to be something I've spent decades on so
it's kind of cool that um uh that it's
it's important seems to be enhanced by
um
um by by the by the advances in in
generative Ai and so on
um
let's see
it's a question from just here does chat
gbt have the ability to mimic emotion
does the fact that chart GPT sort of
mimics emotions meaning that it's able
to feel things
and um
you know
you know I could just say it's a bunch
of artificial neurons that are grinding
out the next word uh you know that are
applying all these neurons and grinding
out the next word does it feel anything
well guess what we're a bunch of neurons
that are grinding out the next word do
we feel anything interesting question so
one feature of chat GPT is it really has
two phases in its existence its training
phase and its execution its so-called
inference phase
um where it's generating stuff it
doesn't right now have the a well it has
a little bit of this actually but but it
doesn't have on a major scale it doesn't
have the ability to kind of learn on an
ongoing basis from what it's doing
now I think part of the reason for that
um the way that neural Nets artificial
neural Nets work right now I said it has
175 billion weights those are stored in
computer memory or whatever
um the the way computers work is they
tend to have a CPU and it maybe it has a
few uh sort of channels of activity in
it but relative to the memory of a
computer you might have a terabyte of
memory in a computer a trillion bytes of
memory in a computer
um but your CPU is just operating on
this you know I don't know a few hundred
bytes at a time it's it's doing this
tiny little sort of peephole uh of of
dealing with the whole memory of the
machine and so the way that neural Nets
are trained right now is based on the
idea that you are just looking at this
people you've got this big area of all
this memory but you're you're just
making changes in this very local area
our brains work differently our brains
uh the hardware of our brains is such
that presumab probably we can make
changes anywhere all the time we're kind
of a continually active memory as
opposed to a computer which is mostly
memory that's fixed and this little CPU
that's running around effectively making
small changes so the current
architecture for training neural Nets is
still very much the sort of peephole
type thing where you're making the small
changes at a time so I think that that's
some
that's a difference now by the time
you've got this uh this kind of
artificial neural net you know AI
generative AI system whatever that is
learning from its experiences and it's
building up this whole rich life
experience and then you say well we got
this whole thing and it's gone to all
this trouble it's been wandering around
the world it's embedded in a robot it's
been you know it's been it's been seeing
the sights of the world it's been having
all these experiences it's storing all
this information and now you know what
do we think about that how do we compare
that to a brain interesting question you
know do we feel that that thing has as
much kind of um you know do we how do we
ethically feel for example about that
thing whole different topic
um but uh I think the um this this
question of sort of what is the inner
feeling
I you know I think in the end uh it's
well this is again a complicated
philosophical issue which I thought Lots
about and this will take us far afield
to discuss the question of what it what
it's like from inside a computer what
it's like from inside another brain you
know it's it's like I have my brain and
mind and I have this one thread of
experience that's me and I see other
people and they seem to be having
threads of experience that are sort of
similar to mine but I'm not inside there
I don't really know what's happening all
I can do is kind of poke at it and you
know Peak at the results as I you know
say something to them and they something
say something back to me it's it's all
from the outside it's not an experience
from the inside but as you start
thinking about what is the experience
from the inside for a computer or
something like that I think it's more
similar to The Experience from the
inside that we have
um as individual Minds than you might
think
uh
okay
um
okay Benny as I was asking
about video and learning from video
do I think that one will be able to
learn kind of how stuff works just by
watching videos or do you think you'll
actually have to put Newton's laws or
something actual physics laws into the
system I don't know the answer my guess
is for a lot of kind of everyday video
it will be completely adequate to um to
just use kind of experiential video my
guess is that just like for us humans
there are situations where people say oh
look you know you've got this top that's
spinning and suddenly it turns itself
upside down you know likely the system
won't it's not going to know it's going
to do that that's something that is a
complicated piece of application of laws
of physics and just sort of the everyday
observation of a top is like it just
does what it does and it doesn't
suddenly tip itself upside down so I
think that the there will be things that
yes you could get them correctly there
were things that unexpected to us humans
that you know for people like me who
spent a lifetime kind of sort of
absorbing physics and so on some of
these things where you see something
weird happen it's like that was weird
and for me I can sometimes say you know
well I know the underlying physics of
that and I know why that weird thing
happened but that wouldn't have been
what intuitively I think just on my
everyday experience of things would be
the way that things work and it's just
like 500 years ago when people said you
know what do you mean the Earth is
moving around the Sun the Earth isn't
moving I'm right here nothing's moving
here
um and you know you have to kind of
learn the physics to get
um to realize that the things that are
your immediate sort of sensory
impression aren't aren't right
um
let's see
oh William is commenting how does chat
GPT experience time and so on how does
the neural net in general experience
time chat gpt's notion of time is
incredibly simple because it's outer
loop is basically just you're gonna
you've got these tokens make the next
token you've got these tokens make the
next token it's it's in a sense having
an external driver of time
I think that for brains the the driver
of time is more it is this computation
happened this next computation happened
it is our realization that we figured
out more thoughts happened those
thoughts correspond to computations in
our brains and it's the passage of
thoughts happening that is the way that
we assess the kind of the passage of
time
um
I think it's an interesting question not
relevant yet for chat GPT and so on this
question of whether there's a sort of
single thread of experience which is one
of the things that's critical to our
sort of human thinking
um the AIS that we're building right now
are very much single threat of
experience type AIS because their goal
is to interface with the world as we
humans experience the world it's it
would be amusing and it's something you
know I spend a lot of time just looking
out into the computational universe of
possible programs and seeing what's out
there what do those things do most of
what they do is very non-human and
non-human relatable just like you know
processes in the natural world whether
it's you know the weather or something
like that is a process that does things
but it isn't necessarily human relatable
what it's doing and so that that's um uh
this this question of I mean the AIS
that we tend to build are human
relatable AIS and so they're they're
um that that's some
uh so they tend to have this sort of
single thread of experience built in
when we have more AIS from the wild the
random AI that we didn't specifically
engineer that was kind of the natural AI
so to speak
um then it may not have single thread of
experience but it may be a very
non-trivial thing to make the bridge
from kind of the the natural AI to how
humans think about things it's very
similar to what happens with the natural
world the natural world does what it
does we have to make this bridge to
Human Experience how do we explain
what's happening in the natural world
how do we tell a story in physics or
something about how the natural world is
working that requires that we actually
do science to make that bridge between
the natural world and our thinking about
the natural world and I think sort of
um you know AI from the wild so to speak
will have the same issue we're already
having the issue I mean there's there's
surely going to be a profession coming
up of sort of AI Wrangler AI
psychologists um I think Isaac Asimov
had already sort of had one of those in
his robot books of kind of the the you
know I'm an AI psychologist and I can
understand why did what is chat GPT
going to do if you feed it this kind of
thing what you know get an intuition in
our human brains for what's happening in
its in its artificial brain and I think
that's a lot easier for something like
chat GPT that's been built to be
specifically aligned with things like
the single threat of Human Experience by
the time you're trying to be the
psychologist so to speak for this AI
from the wild that's more like one of
these simple programs that I might study
or some of these things that come up in
our physics project well that's what it
means to be kind of a natural scientist
and that's you know that is the thing
that people like me have spent a very
long time trying to get intuition for
how things in the general computational
world not the computational world that's
specifically aligned with humans how
those General things work and I will say
it's hard I mean my sort of motto about
those things is when you when you're
doing these experiments these computer
experiments you're looking at this
computational world of programs that you
just sort of made up at random for
example my my typical motto is the
computational animals are always smarter
than you are that is these things you
make computationally they always do
things you don't expect in other words
I've spent you know much of my life
trying to develop an intuition for how
these computational systems work but
even so the one thing that I know is
that I know I'm not going to be able to
guess what they're going to do
um this is in a sense this is this
phenomenon I call computational
irreducibility this is one of its
manifestations in in sort of practical
experience
um
right well I should uh
I should go back to my day job here and
um uh finish some things there but uh
thank you for that um all those
interesting questions and so on and uh
look forward to uh
chatting with you all another time and I
I'm um uh I will say one of the things
that um I am doing is packaging up uh
sort of all of the text that I know I've
produced in my life
um so that I can train a bot that um
will at least locally kind of yak like
me so to speak
um it's about uh well current estimates
about 15 million words of email over the
last 33 years uh 34 years maybe now
um about uh
seven million words
um just in the last year or two in in
live stream transcripts things like this
another
two million words I think
of
things that I've written as some in my
writings website and so on
um over the last decade or so
um that are you know written for
publication so to speak so anyway I'm
I'm it'll be interesting to see I mean I
will have probably I've got um
oh maybe altogether
on the order of I don't know 30 million
words of of of things I've said and the
question is given that that sort of
superimposed on top of general knowledge
of the world and English and so on
um how how good
um you know how successful will that be
at uh at um saying things like I do I'd
like to think that um us humans still
have a bit of an edge
um at least until that you know
modifiable uh uh globally modifiable
memory thing is is a is a reality from
electronics and of course the scary
thing at some level uh if we're proud to
be human so to speak is that uh our
human neurons uh maybe a thousand times
a second they can produce another bit of
information for our computers it's a
billion times a second so the it's uh
computer is a million times faster it
just can't do that across all of its
memory in the same kind of way that that
we can so you know it'll be interesting
to see
um
I am curious
you know in in
when you deal with sort of
um you know humans and talking to humans
and you know you think quickly you think
slowly you know maybe those differences
are very small
you change that by a factor of a million
and you think a million times faster
what does that really look like what
does that feel like what does a
conversation feel like if you say well
you're going to think a million times
faster but you're still talking to that
slow brained you know millisecond time
scale human and and you've got to scale
back down from the million times faster
to the uh you know to the to the human
do you in fact end up with something
that's pretty much the same thing
um or do you end up with something very
different where you know in that moment
of conversation you know a lifetime of
figuring out things has happened those
kinds of things are are possible and I I
certainly think um you know if I look at
things I've done in in my life it's
sometimes taken me decades to figure
things out factor of a million faster
well could could happen in much less
time
all right uh I've got to got to go here
so um I will uh
uh thank you and see you another time